hey folks
brett here i have a prediction the
prediction is the dark horse
podcast will go live in about five
minutes
but in order for that to happen we need
to know if the video is coming through
if the audio
is loud enough and in sync if everything
is working to your satisfaction enough
that you will tune in
and be i don't know occupied with
content rather than the tech that's what
we'd like so please tell us in the chat
whether everything seems to be working
if there's anything you think we ought
to know some kind of troubleshooting we
should do
in advance of the dark horse podcast
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast
live stream 47th if i'm not mistaken
you're not mistaken this time it is
prime it is prime and you know what i
discovered
no it is september this totally caught
me by surprise but it appears not only
to be september but we are now
deeply into september yeah don't get
used to it really
oh my god you know something i don't i
do i have a calendar oh
crap all right i've got to get a
calendar i should put that on my
to-do list i guess yeah all right well
we have a lot to talk about we have uh
it's been a week since our last podcast
am i correct
it's been a week it has been a week all
right so we are back
um i'm trying to recall you and i had a
discussion about where to start
we are starting with you want to start
with unity unity ah
right unity yes all right folks so um
there is an update with respect to unity
which those of you who have been
attending our campfires will know about
but the rest of you should know
so the unity 2020 plan involved
a proposal to draft candidates to elect
to the white house
it came with a pair of failsafes to
prevent it from spoiling
the election one of those failsafes was
if as the election approached we did not
have a viable path to victory we would
pull the plug on the plan so that it
couldn't spoil the election
and we have arrived the decision that
this is that moment
now were there to be some sort of
an emergency that would cause the
electorate to wake up to the danger that
we are in all of a sudden and to go
groping for a better plan
than the major parties have delivered us
the plan
could be rebooted but that is not our
expectation
so let me tell you a little bit about
what this does and doesn't mean
it means that we are not going to
attempt to draft our ticket
but what we have recognized in the
process of
working on unity 2020 is that the
plan is part of a larger movement and
the movement is one
that stands against the things that have
corrupted
our governmental structure and the need
for it
is as great or greater than it was when
we started it so
the movement is going to continue we are
going to look
to the long term and attempt to figure
out how it is that we can
rescue our republic from the death
spiral
that its political class has
inflicted upon it so that's where we
stand with unity 2020
not uh the best news but not hopeless
not an end well let me say i'm not even
it's not the best
news the best news would have been uh
that
come january 2021 we are welcoming unity
ticket to the white house
and uh it looks like god all the color
metaphors you can imagine a light at the
end of the tunnel blue skies overhead
all of this i mean as we said in our in
our founding document
imagine that a pair of courageous
capable patriots were
ascending to be sworn in how what kind
of you know sigh of relief
would relief would the country
collectively breathe and so that was
always
the objective on the other hand i would
point out that you know you and i have
talked a lot in the context of
education and in the context of other
phenomena about the importance of a
prototyping
mindset and that's right everything good
that is complex
arises through an iterated process of
discovery
right i should look up whether or not
edison in fact
said that at the point that he
had succeeded he had discovered a
thousand ways not to make a light bulb
or something to that effect but the
point is
we discovered a tremendous amount in
this process about what needs to take
place
in order to fix the uh the corruption
that has
uh disrupted governance and there's
there is
a tremendous amount of of goodwill
and pressure and force in in the right
in the you know physics sense
of the term um behind this you know it
was it was apparent
that there is as you and i and many
others have long suspected
a real visceral
intellectual and emotional desire to see
a fix
uh and that fix might well look like
this yeah it really
lacked one thing which was uh
exponential
growth which you know in some sense is
the thing
on the other hand what it did do was
surface
the the underlying belief structure of a
great many patriots
and so you know does it set the stage
for us to do something in the future
that could in fact
recapture the white house or other
structures on behalf of the people
i think it revealed the path there and
so you know personally
i um i
feel imperiled to know that what is very
likely to happen
is you know we were going to get one the
the duopoly's version a or b right
that's a very frightening prospect
um and i wish we i wish somebody had
figured out a way out of that mess
didn't happen so okay that's frightening
on the other hand
i'm not the least bit disappointed at
what happened here i think
we beat expectations by a lot right
we ran a successful ranked choice vote
we had
high level discussions with lots of
people both you know on our campfires
and behind the scenes
and so we did discover that the niche in
question exists and the question is
what do you do with it so we will see
going forward but
uh if you have been following unity 2020
please know that what has changed is the
unity 2020 plan itself
the unity movement still exists and is
as dedicated as ever to the prospect of
fixing our system
perhaps something like unity 2020 is
dead
long live unity i like that i wouldn't
say dead it's
uh unity 2020 yeah is dead this was
about a particular moment in time
right this is about a particular
presidential election appending the 2020
to it
so just like the king is dead long live
the king refers to two different
instantiations of the king
unity 2020 is presumably not the name of
the movement going forward because
it pinpoints the origin date and it's a
forward-looking movement
right yeah though my concern was not
with the unity 2020 part it's with
dead because the prototype mindset i
you know is it dead but it doesn't
matter it's a semantic question
there are multiple lenses with which to
approach something and i
obviously agree with the prototype lens
but using a phrase from history doesn't
render the prototype lens
inoperable right except that you have
neglected the fact that history is
itself a
tool of oppression and therefore we must
you know that's cheating
i'm kidding i know it was only a joke
all right
so that's the unity 2020 update the
unity movement continues this is
we're trying to model this right like
when people pull that [ __ ] on you that's
cheating
stop right and the way you really stop
them is the eyebrows the
double raised eyebrow thing that's a
shot across the bow so
all right maybe a slight eye roll and a
slack jaw oh god
oh yeah yeah the eye roll and the up to
the right
thing man yeah that is uh that's a
warning
okay so next topic was
uh i wanted to talk about the technical
difficulties and
again you all probably don't care very
much about the technical yeah we don't
you're not interested in talking about
technical difficulties
this is in service of understanding how
to make sense in the world so
let me before you start we want to talk
a little bit about this
sort of how to take a problem that
we happen to have experienced and apply
a careful scientific approach to it
in order to try to make sense of the
world uh
segwaying from there into how is it that
so many of us
are having a hard time making sense of
what is being
provided to us and what it looks like
the other side is saying about who we
are
that is to say to what degree are the
reflections being shown back at us
actually accurate um and then i want to
talk a little bit about the downstream
effects of some of the
um you know batshit nonsense coming out
of um
gender theory cool i wish it wasn't
called bat [ __ ] nonsense but i get it
yeah
so i i need a prop for this can you hand
me the cat yeah oh absolutely always
all right here we go the cat right now
the cat let's be fair facts
right yeah the cat is a complex system
yes and this is a complex system with so
much complexity
that it's very difficult to sort out
what's going on uh
that drives it and causes it to behave
the way that it does
something like the uh apparatus we use
to do
podcasting is a complex system that is
so many orders of magnitude less complex
that it actually lends itself to
uh scientific solving more simply right
it does it's not going to require
years of study to figure out how it
works and to troubleshoot it okay you
know that i'm going to put an asterisk
here and say you know as
as an animal behaviorist i will i
constantly aspire to try to understand
the complex system that is the cat oh
you and me both on the other hand we
both know that we are a million miles
collectively scientifically from
understanding how a single cell in that
animal works
right and that animal is composed of oh
at least hundreds of billions of cells
so in any case there is so much mystery
left in that complex system that it is
still orders of magnitude short
even if we can skip to something like
the behavior of the animal and say
actually we know an awful lot about why
it does what it does and then there's
you know the residual the mystery that's
still left which is the part that you
and i
find the most fascinating but all right
back to this mini complex system that is
our podcast apparatus
those who are paying attention around um
live stream number 45 i believe
will remember that we were inundated by
smoke
um and that the uh cameras were
all dropping out somewhat regularly no
matter what camera angle
zach put on us the signal would drop out
and you would see
rainbow color bars indicating the
absence of signal
and as i said last time we did a ton of
troubleshooting to figure out what might
be going on it was all three cameras two
other cameras
did it ultimately we discovered that it
was
many devices in the house that put out
signal over hdmi
and nothing that was uninvolved in hdmi
this led us to the question of was there
some kind of radiation
that might be affecting the system
and somebody one of our viewers
suggested it could possibly be radon
which would make sense because we had
the windows closed due to the smoke here
in portland
and radon which is the product of
radioactive decay
of uh isotopes in the soil the radon is
produced by that decay
larger heavier elements break down radon
is one of the products it's a gas it
floats up from your crawl space
and if your house is well sealed it can
be trapped and if the levels rise to a
high enough degree
it can interfere you know with your
cells for one thing it can cause
mutations and things so somebody
suggested maybe
our windows being tightly closed during
the smoke period had caused radon to
build up we have a radon problem
i tested that hypothesis i got a radon
detector i've let it run for a week
we have low levels of radon so that's
not it so that's
again leaves us with this mystery and as
as often
uh with careful scientific
investigations
you're left with some relief that you
haven't been poisoned within your home
in this case
and some disappointment that you have
not apparently come
on the hypothesis that is likely to be
true
so right not that falsified radon so
hypothesis it's radon build up and that
would be consistent with the windows
being closed prediction
if you test for radon you will find high
levels of it falsified no we don't find
higher levels of radon well but
so as we did last time one prediction of
that hypothesis
is but it's not a exclusive prediction
of this hypothesis
is once you open your windows the
problems will be resolved
the problems were resolved once we
opened the windows so that was
coincident with the hypothesis that it
was radon being trapped in the house
but it also is also a prediction of
other hypothesis
other hypotheses so it's not a strong
prediction on account of being a
prediction that follows from
all possible hypotheses the problem is
the multiple hypotheses are pretty
exotic
right so it does seem clear we have some
kind of interference
it's some kind of interference that
seems to register on hdmi and nothing
else which is
interesting a lot of searching reveals
nothing of that nature
i don't find anything that there's lots
of talk online about
various kinds of electromagnetic
interference but hdmi does not seem
particularly prone
also people noticed that there was a
regular periodicity to the failures of
our cameras
which led many in our audience who were
technically savvy to propose that it had
something to do with a mismatch of frame
rates between our computer and our
cameras
which didn't make a lot of sense because
nothing had changed on that front
and if one camera had gotten out of
whack it wouldn't have been on the
others so it would have had to be in the
computer
and if we swapped in a different
computer it didn't happen so there were
a lot of reasons to think that
hypothesis was wrong
it is i think possible and maybe one of
our
technically savvy viewers will know it
is possible
that radiation of some kind could
disrupt
the time keeping of the hdmi
process which could result in a frame
rate mismatch
that would then go away when whatever
the radiation or interference
disappeared from the system so that
would match the pattern if it were true
that electromagnetic interference could
disrupt or
radiation either one could disrupt the
time keeping
then at the point that that interference
is gone
the time keeping would go back to normal
so just once again to lay out
what changed so you and zach did a
tremendous amount of troubleshooting
inside with the system with the you know
man-made parts of the system and nothing
seemed to address the issue
we were in you know smoke lockdown for
10 to 12
days depending on how you count on
friday of last week
eight days ago the rains came the air
cleared
we opened the windows so really two big
things it was all
of a system but two big things changed
at once not only
did the air quality in our house become
much better because we were able to open
the windows but the air quality in our
entire environment
um improved and you know often often
those will be coincident with one
another but they were
explicitly um happened within 24 hours
of one another
right so um so and as that happened
all of the problems uh that we've been
having disappeared
every single one and so i would i would
remind people we tried two other cameras
that only gave us an hdmi output a
different brand
two different models they all showed
this flaw so it was something very
general
and the fact of the end of the smoke
the beginning of the reigns and the
opening of the windows all being exactly
consistent in time
and being consistent with the end of our
problems
uh is very conspicuous in fact i think
it's
highly likely that whatever it was about
the the reigns triggered all those other
behaviors and one of them
fixed our problem so what's your new
hypothesis well i don't want to say
your new hypothesis because this is you
generated this hypothesis
your new hypothesis does not mean
although it is often
understood to mean in journalism and
common parlance
your preferred hypothesis the thing you
think to be true the thing you want to
be true
in this case it is i think neither yep
right and
you those so there's three things you
generated it
you generated it you generated it you
think it's true you want it to be true
often um you know often people
will have a hypothesis of which all
three of those things are true and
frankly the scientific method is the way
of getting rid of the bias around i
really want this to be true
the scientific method doesn't care if uh
if you generated it um or if you think
it's true it shouldn't
but the the the bias that the scientific
method the careful application the
scientific method is supposed to remove
is anything that you might be doing
unconsciously or consciously in order to
get a result
that you think is true or that you favor
being true
right and so to put a finer point on
this you can generate and in fact it is
good
practice when you are studying
scientifically to generate
every conceivable hypothesis that could
explain an observation
and that means that you hold if we're
going to say these are your hypotheses
because you generated them all
the point is you don't hold one as the
one you're rooting for or expecting
though you may be that's also possible
but in this case
we are left with a hypothesis that i
find
possible whether or not i think it's
likely
we'll have to talk a little bit more in
detail and i certainly don't want it to
be true
but here it is the hypothesis
is that there was radiation that
was trapped in our forests
now at some level that's automatically
true we already know that this will be
true because
from any event that has released
radiation
when the weather carries the particles
from that event
over some landscape and then it rains we
know that rain carries these particles
to the ground right so
after a meltdown for example the rains
nuclear meltdown
nuclear meltdown you have you know
particles released
you have winds carry them somewhere
which is
you know often quite arbitrary and then
rains which cause a
very concentrated danger at the moment
that the particles are
carried to the ground and concentrated
but the hypothesis here is that
radiation
possibly from something like fukushima
which we do know
blew to the pacific northwest that's one
of the places that it was
uh that it landed in particular so just
just a reminder for
people who don't most people will
recognize the word fukushima but perhaps
not have a
two-sentence description on it you know
2011
uh meltdown following a tsunami triple
meltdown
so the fukushima daiichi complex has
six reactors and seven fuel pools
spent fuel pools are where the reactor
cores that have been spent
go and they for so uh nuclear fuel
is loaded into these things nuclear fuel
is a
a purified radioactive material mostly
uranium although one of the reactors at
fukushima was loaded with what's called
mixed oxide fuel mox
mox fuel contains uh
plutonium from weapons that have been
decommissioned so it's basically a
process of using that it's
uh so one of the reactors was loaded
with that but
the thing that is hard to intuit is that
the use of the uranium the enriched
uranium in the
uh reactors causes the production of a
whole
slew of isotopes that weren't in it to
begin with right including lots of
really
crazy bad stuff like very long-lived
plutonium
isotopes with very long half-lives
and some very short-lived stuff too
right it produces iodine
uh i think it's 152 that has a half
i know it's tiny it's not gonna be no
um never mind yes one of the iodine
isotopes and it has an eight day
half-life which means that it degrades
very quickly but but it's actually the
intermediate-sized
um elements that are most concerning
right so
you're going to get there but iodine is
so small and has such a short half-life
that it is you know
nine years later it is mostly not mostly
not around and concerning
um as a result of the fukushima meltdown
uranium plutonium etc are still around
but probably did not cross the pacific
ocean
in at least in in any sort of large
amounts whereas it's those intermediate
sized
atoms like strontium and cesium which
would have basically got you know
traveled on particulate matter attached
themselves
crossed dropped themselves on the in the
pacific northwest why because
as a as a friend of ours whom i was
teaching with many years ago once said
to me
once described the pacific northwest as
the windshield of the continent the
windshield of north america it's a
perfect description
and you know jack if you're out there hi
from the dark horse podcast yeah it's
just it's it's such an apt description
and it really does
it helps it helps us understand so much
about our climate our weather
our biota to some degree even our
culture at least certainly
pre-columbian cultures here but but i
digress
so the windshield of the continent
collects all of this weather that's been
blowing over the pacific and nine years
ago that weather
included um a lot of radioactive
strontium and cesium
that then got dropped in rainfall into
our forests
so strontium and caesium are
both also
front of mind because they each mimic
an element that we use physiologically
so if you eat something that has
radioactive
strontium in it it's very likely i
believe strontium goes to bones and
lodges itself there
and cesium goes to muscle so these are
bio biotically dangerous because we
metabolize them and build them into our
uh our bodily structure but i mean
iodine is obviously
very biologically dangerous as well for
thyroid fibroids exactly
so but you can replace so this is the
reason actually you can replace if you
know that you might be at risk of being
dosed by radioactive iodine
you can take non-radioactive iodine
effectively fill up your
your bucket your iodine bucket fill the
fiber right in there and leave the
radioactive iodine no place to bind to
in your thyroid
um until the risk is passed exactly okay
but you can't buy bottles of
non-radioactive strontium and cesium the
way you can buy bottles of donative
iodine well it doesn't really work that
way because the thyroid
is functioning differently right so
building into bone is a long-term
process
that you're constantly doing and so
anyway um
cesium and strontium oh and also there's
another way that these things could get
into our forests
right which is actually again these
things again being radioactive iso
radioactive isotopes of strontium and
season that's what these things mean
radioactive isotopes of cesium and
strontium could get into our forest in
the following way
they don't even have to come here by
wind they could wash
off the shores of japan right because a
lot of the stuff landed in japan
as well they could wash off the shores
of of japan
and into the pacific they could find
themselves incorporated into fish
right especially tuna were tested at the
time
and were very likely to be
uh containing radioactive isotopes from
fukushima
also salmon and the thing is salmon have
this
uh obviously ecological habit of
reproducing in these freshwater
watersheds
throughout the pacific northwest right
in a different state but you know
populations
uh you know the salmon ecology is
fascinating we should spend a couple of
episodes probably talking about salmon
at some point
um but even though there is some actual
overlap in species of ankarincus which
is the genus of pacific salmon we're
talking about
um there aren't it would be
we have a lot to say about what happens
when salmon get lost and how they found
new populations
but getting lost from japan and ending
up at the pacific northwest no
individual salmon is going to get that
lost and survived
i don't think it's a matter of lost so
the salmon typically spends something
like four years
at sea and i believe we know that many
salmon
that come from our watersheds do range
as far as japan
and then come back in okay i don't i
don't know this to be true
we will soon find out when all of the
ichthyology types
contact us but in any case the reason i
mention it
is that it is actually it's
counter-intuitive but
true that the riparian zones that is to
say the forest
adjacent to these watersheds
for riparian zones specifically being
forest adjacent to streams and rivers
fast
moving water as opposed to watershed is
just the whole
the the whole area right but it's a
watershed so they it contain
doesn't matter that the fact is you've
got these streams and rivers
in which salmon move up and they
actually change the ecology of these
forests because they do materially alter
what nutrients are available they die in
large numbers this is a big animal they
die in large numbers bears and other
things drag their carcasses
into the forest some distance and then
whatever it is
uh that was in those animals makes its
way into the soil and then into the
trees
so just this was this is one of the real
successes i think of ecology from the
90s and early aughts was this concept of
marine derived nutrients
in terrestrial forests terrestrial
forest is redundant
um i guess kelp forest so i'm not
talking about kelp forests i'm talking
about
marine derived nutrients in what all of
us think of when we think of forests
is exactly it happens exactly as you
just described and specifically nitrogen
was tracked
nitrogen was tracked um because it
because it
like like everything decays at a certain
rate and
the the fact of nitrogen that had been
the oceans now being visible
um be findable and trackable in
um in furs and in in doug furs
in the pacific northwest and in bears
and in other things that
end up not only eating the salmon
directly as bears
do in some cases but being effectively
downstream of the effects of the corpses
of the salmon that decay
and move their marine derived nutrients
including nitrogen into the soil
into the foliage browsed by deer you
know so
this you know this this nitrogen that
was in the middle of the pacific ocean
not too long ago
is now living in some deer in idaho and
we actually have a decent sense of how
that happened
yes and it's an amazing story right so
you can imagine
uh you know if you if the nitrogen were
color-coded
and you were looking down on a map
there's some big pulse in the fall as
some
you know salmon species returns to a
given river and then
it moves out into the immediately
adjacent space as these dead carcasses
get washed around and stuff like that
it gets moved farther by big animals
like bears that might drag the stuff
farther than that um you know the bear
shits in the woods yes they do
and uh you know flies might carry a
little bit
you know a little bit farther afield so
you can imagine these nutrients moving
out of these
rivers right and that this is a process
that actually is an equilibrium that
replenishes the nutrients that are lost
from all of the stuff that washed
downstream and into the oceans
all right beautiful so there is all of
that
there is 2011 triple
meltdown less beautiful so much less
beautiful triple meltdown at fukushima
dumps a lot of stuff into the ocean
um and a lot of stuff blows in the
atmosphere due to the particular weather
in the days following
that blew into the pacific northwest
right
so here's the hypothesis the hypothesis
and it is
known is is it known that i thought you
would also say that it was known that
um there was particulate matter
including radiation from fukushima
that did blow into the pacific northwest
and the weeks thereafter that was
known absolutely and at some point
crazily
and not reported on enough data actually
stopped being collected
right so but but this was we we know
this to be true
that's right we know this to be true um
we know this to be true and if i recall
correctly the methodology
involved the air filters of automobiles
which trapped
in japan right in the pacific northwest
that trapped radioactive
particles and so if you could get a
filter from somebody's car that they had
driven during those weeks
and then you um you know i think the
methodology involved laying it down on a
piece of photographic
paper that was sensitive then the little
disintegrations the nuclear
disintegrations that happen would result
in a black spot on the film
right and you compare that to the
filters of cars that had not been driven
during those weeks
right and the fact is it varies based on
very local
weather patterns you know it rains here
it doesn't rain there
you get a pulse the air clears over
there and so the cars aren't inhaling it
so
the particular weather matters a lot but
okay but we know it's just
fascinating that um that the methodology
involved
effectively looking at the respiratory
structures of cars right right
the respiratory system and it's exactly
what's going on
right um so and you know right down to
the
point why does a car breathe right a car
is breathing in
oxygen in order to fuel combustion
which is what causes it to go and we
could say the exact same thing about you
the difference is
your combustion isn't fire it's a
chemical combustion without flame
but nonetheless same damn process that's
respiration is
gas exchange gas exchange so in animals
it looks one way and plants it looks
almost the opposite in cars it looks a
bit different yet
but it's all a kind of respiration it's
gas exchange and
exchange at the molecular level when you
burn fuel in your car you're
you're burning um you're burning
carbon bonds that were
forged in an ancient peat bog in general
um part of an ancient dinosaur right
something
peat bogs generate a lot more so most of
the gasoline in your car comes from a
peat bog that got
uh buried and you know turned into crude
oil over time but anyway
photosynthesis captured the energy from
the sun loaded it into these bonds
between
carbon molecules it was then underground
for millions of years somebody
you know drills it refines it puts it in
your car and you release the energy from
the sun that was trapped in these
molecules
through combustion just the same way if
you eat a carrot you then internally
release the energy that was stored by
the carrot plant
you know in the carbon bonds um to fuel
motion and other things that require
energy
it's uh it's a lot less energy that you
require and that you're releasing from
the carrot
right but i always uh when i was
teaching i love to
talk about my fusion powered bicycle
um because my bicycle actually is fusion
powered um as is yours
uh because basically the point is it's
fusion in the sun
that releases the energy that gets
captured by the
carrot or the stock of wheat or the cow
ultimately yes yeah um and then you know
you release it and so your
fusion energy in it yeah sun to grass to
cow to your plate to you to fueling your
bicycle fueling my bicycle right bicycle
okay so we are now far afield from the
tech failure and the hypothesis that's
good but the hypothesis
is yes radioactive material
it doesn't have to be from fukushima it
could be from an earlier event like
weapons tests
but we know there to have been a pulse
we know that there was a pulse from
fukushima right
whatever pulses it was then drifted
rains dropped stuff onto the ground
which we also know happened
it happened in particular places and not
other places right you would have to go
back and look at the exact weather
pattern to know where it landed and
where it didn't
but a fire that then burns the plants
that will have incorporated these
radioactive isotopes
would then release that radiation into
the air and so you just i think you just
skipped one piece that will be obvious
to many but not to everyone which is
that
uh a pulse that that comes our way
that drops to the ground is then pulled
up by the roots of plants because it
becomes part of the soil because
it's tiny it's it's it's atomic isotopes
that are bonded to little pieces of dust
that are themselves incorporated
into into the root systems because that
is not the breathing the breathing is
through the leaves
um but the eating uh is in some ways
not the sugars which is through the
leaves but uh is um
is through the roots right the
micronutrients are pulled up
micronutrients nutrients will be pulled
up through the roots incorporated into
the plants
yeah um you could detect it in the
plants and i'm sure people have done
that work occasionally
yeah we should have looked into that i'm
sure i'm sure they have a parallel
um parallel piece of information just so
people understand what these systems are
like i remember
nalini who is actually uh
scientist in her own right so married to
jack who was the source of the
beautiful quote about this being the
windshield of the continent this is
nalini nadkari and jack longino
um so nalini who was an expert on
mosses and cannon and forced cancer
talked about the event the
mount st helens eruption which had
trapped a layer
of ash in the mosses that
persists to this day in our trees and
has effects so if you go into the canopy
of trees and you find patches of moths
that are old enough
you've effectively got this layer of ash
and it turns out i think i learned this
from nalini
that the ash got incorporated
into the trees and the grit is
actually causes chainsaw blades to wear
faster here if you're cutting trees that
were downstream of that
event downstream in time no that got
ash on downstream in ash yes okay and so
national ash fell really hard in olympia
in seattle in portland portland more
than
more than seattle yeah and so that ash
fell in all of these forests and somehow
the grit
is uh causing chainsaw blades to uh
erode faster but anyway an aside so
here's the hypothesis the hypothesis is
something maybe fukushima released
nuclear radiation in the form of all of
these isotopes that are created in the
heart of a reactor could also be true
from a weapon
the material
fell here as a result of weather having
it blown this direction
and rain having caused it to fall to the
ground gets incorporated into the trees
a fire event releases this stuff
it will have then been floating in the
air and these macroscopic smoke
particles that were making it so hard to
see
and to breathe now i don't think the
concentrations of those things would
have been high in our house because we
sealed off our house and we had a filter
pulling the smoke particles out of the
air at a higher rate
so there would have been little bursts
here like atomic radiation like
at the elemental level would not be
trapped by hepa felt it would be too
small
but the particulate matter that would
have been released in the form of smoke
through fire would um would have been
trapped by a hepa filter so let's be
clear about this
radiation won't be trapped in any
circumstance
an atom a radioactive atom won't be
trapped because it's too small right
right and so we talked on our last
podcast about radon which is a gas which
wouldn't be trapped at all by a filter
right but a particle a radioactive
particle that is
in wood or leaves that then gets
liberated into the air is
ash that's now in a macroscopic particle
and that will get trapped by
by a filter so my guess is we didn't
have high rates of that stuff
in the house and despite the fact that
the air outside was absolutely choking
we actually did not have terrible
respiratory issues in the house
during that time which suggests that our
air was pretty clean
but there's a question about the
radiation the ambient radiation
could the ambient radiation cause first
of all some radiation will get through
uh things like walls and windows and
some won't so the question is would
there be ambient radiation
that would be capable of disrupting our
podcast system
in here that would have almost
immediately ceased or immediately ceased
as soon as the rains
pulled the particles out of the air and
washed them
into the stream um
so that is a hypothesis how would you
test it
well one thing you could do is and this
is in theory doable it becomes less
practical every day
there are cars that were driven during
that time we drove both of our vehicles
during that time though not very much
those cars will have pulled in a sample
of what was in the atmosphere and it
will decay at whatever rate the
particular isotopes decay at whatever
their half-life is
so that would be detectable and cars
that were
here but not driven during that time
won't have trapped an appreciable amount
of it
and so you could test it in that way
yeah and um
despite the admittedly very patchy
presumably patchy distribution
of radioactive isotopes in the forest of
the pacific northwest and this
hypothesis hinges on the idea that at
least some of the forest i mean there's
such a
giant spot of forest that burned that at
least some of those forests would have
been
high density of radioactive isotopes
but you know carefully in a controlled
fashion
taking a couple of adjoining trees from
each of these places and burning them
into a container
and measuring uh the radioactivity
in that in that burn or you know just
just burning them into a filter and then
doing exactly the same thing
so it would not be testing what happened
but it would be
a decent way of mimicking what happened
that doesn't depend on doing it right
now you know it doesn't depend on
collecting data that are
aging every day because the fires are in
the past and in fact
now that you mention it there's a very
good method that you could deploy here
which is you could take a round from a
tree
right you could buck a tree you can take
a tree that was near the fires but not
in them there's gotta be plenty of that
right yeah cut it down take a
a round and now you have tree rings
which will tell you how long ago a
deposit was laid down yes so you could
figure out actually
if if there is appreciable radiation
where it came from where's the pulse
um so anyway that would be very
interesting yeah no and there
there are a lot of fallen and snag trees
uh that are
you know at risk of falling in the
coming rains and causing mudslides and
mudslides that are then more dangerous
because they bring down uh trees as well
so
there will be lots of such material
available
uh for such analysis should someone have
simply the the time and the resources to
do it yeah we just
we don't have the we don't have the
technology to do such analysis but
right now i will say the nice thing
about the methodology
that you point to is that it doesn't the
ability to test this doesn't degrade
exactly right yeah i mean those the to
the degree that there are snags and
fallen trees right now that might
that might be beginning to be cleaned up
so as to render
the probably coming mud slides uh less
dangerous they might get disappeared a
little bit but there's
there's plenty of stuff to buck up and
uh and and do this analysis on
but even if you didn't you could test so
with my method
of the air filters in the cars um
you can't do this the farther we get
from the fire event the less likely it
is to work because
cars that were idle will have been
driven you'll pollute the data
but the trees that weren't burned the
ones adjacent to these
areas that did burn just simply retain
their level of radiation which will
decay at its natural rate
i do like the idea of pollution
polluting the pollution data
polluting you with noise exactly yeah
okay so noise that's the solution data a
reminder
i am not saying that i believe that this
is what happened to our system the truth
is i don't know what i believe happened
to our system
the reason that i am more likely to
believe this hypothesis then probably
anybody listening to this podcast who is
tracking this
is that i know that zach and i falsified
just about everything that was more
likely than this and
several times over right the number of
things that we were able to eliminate
by just simply swapping in a different
piece of equipment or testing
you know something there rather than
here we falsified
virtually everything we were left with
it has to be some kind of interference
and we do not have a source of
interference that makes any sense
nor do we have a source of interference
that should have gone away at the point
that the rains came and the smoke
changed things nor
had had you guys made changes to the
system in advance of the problems
beginning
nothing and nor did we change anything
back at the point that they were fixed
it was insensitive to for example
humidifying the room so we falsified
static electricity so we falsified so
many hypotheses it was almost
insensitive to applying tinfoil hats
right exactly which frankly we
discovered later needed to be grounded
they would have been much more likely to
work but and it makes for a better
visual too
a grounded tinfoil hat is just even
better totally yeah it's not as good as
a based tinfoil hat but
all right so that's it this is
hypothesis
predictions uh we'd love to see a test
we'd also love to hear from people who
know more about these topics than we do
i have cons
i have contacted one expert who i'm
hoping will respond and tell us whether
this is plausible or not
but anyway people in our audience may
know too all right
all right i feel good about that what's
next um so
i mean it's a little bit of a strange
segue actually um
because it goes back into the explicitly
political and that you know this
what we what we just did is exactly what
the kind of thing that would emerge
sort of organically in our classrooms
whether or not you know that that
wouldn't have been a topic that i would
likely have prepared
content on but it might well have
emerged and those sorts of conversations
that describe in real time how it is
that you would go about trying to figure
out if something is true
by using the scientific method and your
own background knowledge and trying to
figure out what else you would need to
know in order to assess all like this
this is this is the thing that we do
and that we bring towards all of the
questions that um that we try to address
in life and so i was remembering um you
know we did an event a live event back
when live events happened
in um gosh november of last year maybe
uh
with some here in portland
and i'm just not gonna remember any of
the particulars there was a there was a
screening of a very short documentary
that had nadine strassen
the former president of the aclu and cut
apologies to
the organization that put it on and the
host i can't remember anything i know
that we were on stage with katie herzog
who's awesome former uh journalist with
a stranger now co-host of the
blocked and reported podcast with jesse
single um
and our host uh said to us
presumably there's other things you'd
like to be talking about then
cancel culture and wokeness and
postmodernism and all the stuff that we
have
spent a lot of time talking about in
this podcast um and that we were talking
about that evening and
yeah we said ah yes yes actually you
know we're working on this book
it's about using using evolutionary lens
to understand uh
modernity and yes there are so many
things that we'd rather be talking about
but of course it's also true that you
can use an evolutionary lens to
understand the
modern the modern craziness um so that's
all a little bit of a
uh a disclaimer to say that um
hey i want to talk a little bit about
the modern craziness with judith butler
and
gender theory and such but first um
i've become really so worried
i didn't think it was possible to be
more worried about the state of
political discourse and um
you know what looks like end of empire
level actions on all sides
uh and what i'm seeing now though
is scaring me more because it looks like
people on both sides and you can define
sides a lot of ways but for the moment
let's just call it left and right
um and the sort of not just the woke
left but
almost all of the dams not all of us to
the degree that we're still democrats
but almost all the dems see are willing
to go along with the story
that trump and the far right and white
nationalists and all
are going to usher in an authoritarian
fascistic era
right like that is the analysis that you
see in here
in wapo and new york times and cnn and
msnbc and all this
and similarly many on the right are
convinced that intersectionality and
post-modernism and utopian and communist
fantasies
of a perfect don't know unicorn-filled
future
will usher in an authoritarian fascistic
era and it's really it's the same
language so i found myself a couple of
times this week
um reading you know an analysis of for
instance
a horrifying true tale from yes nazi
germany
and in one case it arrived at see this
is what's coming
if you vote for trump another case that
arrived at see this is what's coming
if you vote for biden and they weren't
exactly the same stories but they were
effectively the same stories
so i don't think we know
what we i don't think anyone now knows
what they look like to the other
i think we are we are being we are being
fed
not just untruths about the other
but we are seeing ourselves reflected in
a way that doesn't
doesn't even remind us of ourselves very
often
and i the this you know this is this is
a term that i guess daniel
schwartenberger has used a lot but this
you know
the the the decline of sense making the
inability to do sense making when we
used to know
how to do it from some combination of
first principles and trusting particular
authorities
and you know there was a newspaper and
of record and it did hold itself to
account and all of these things
without any of those what we're left
with is first principles
and even that given that aside from what
you can
actually see and feel and hear with your
own senses
what do you trust like how do you how do
you even know the basic things that are
true
and therein we land at male is female
and two plus two was five and you know
all of this nonsense
that really does suggest that we're at
the end of
of the ability to determine what's real
and what's not
yeah it's uh um the
the i don't know is the wheels coming
off the apple cart a mixed metaphor or
do i have it right but
um so a couple things i would say is
one you know in biology
homeostasis right the ability to
continue
on for a creature or a cell or anything
is the result of the maintenance of
conditions between
certain bounds right so for us
endotherms so-called warm-blooded
creatures
our temperature is maintained within a
very narrow
scope and all of our enzymes function
on the assumption of that temperature if
your temperature goes up
too high then the point is well your
enzymes are just molecules and their
shape will actually change
based on how warm and chaotic the
environment is so
your temperature is not arbitrarily
chosen it's actually
tightly matched to the enzymes in
question and for those of us who are
endotherms
which has evolved twice more depending
on how you count but twice
in on earth in the form of mammals and
birds separate evolutions of endothermy
that temperature is made created
and maintained internally we can't look
outside of us to
to to to maintain our own heat and
obviously we do
you know we do feel warm in the sun and
feel cold in the cold but
it is our bodies that are doing the
homeostatic work
uh and you know whereas if you're if
you're if you're a lizard you have a
much wider range of possibilities and
you know at some level i don't know if
this is where you were going but um
it almost feels like people are playing
around with the homeostatic
levers of society to such a great degree
that they're imagining that like we're a
lizard it'll be fine it's like no you
know what
we can't function within that kind of
range we're like we're
this our society is an endothermic
society not an ectothermic one and
we we need certain bounds to exist
within which
homeostasis is possible outside of which
all bets are off just you know all
systems start to go haywire and they
will act in unpredictable ways i mean
we know this with things like um we know
this with things like climate we know
this is
with things like policing like both of
them totally different systems but
um you know you pull the levers too far
and
you can't predict what comes next
accurately so this this is more or less
what i was going to say is
what we effectively are seeing are two
sides that are advocating
to pull the lever in their direction and
the point is the purpose of that lever
is about homeostasis right yeah and
to the extent that the body becomes
convinced
that you know warmer is better
it's on the verge of collapse right it's
no better to be convinced that colder is
better
right the point is you want to maintain
temperature in
the functional range and the attack that
you point to
on the very ability to detect what is
even true
is evidence of a system that is in the
process
of unhooking the very things on which
homeostasis
is based yeah and just to extend the
metaphor i think
um the people the people on the left who
are protesting
um let's let's just talk about the good
faith protesters
which i think includes a lot of confused
people but the good faith people
covered in cat for um the good faith
people on the left who
are demanding change now demanding
change um
due to what they see as a you know
systemically racist society that
by some estimations hasn't changed since
selma alabama which is obviously wrong
um but you know they they see something
that
i and many others would argue and can
compellingly argue from data isn't
true but they see that thing and say if
this is true and we say it is true
then we need change now because this is
unconscionable and cannot stand
and so they are effectively acting as
the fever they are acting as the fever
as the we're going to raise the
temperature
on the system so that we can free
ourselves of this infection
um that has been uh the case in western
society from time and memorial
and then we can go back but how dare you
want homeostasis at a time like this
and then there are others of us who say
a lot of what you're saying is based on
bad data and and and bad analysis
that does not suggest that there is no
is no racism
and that there isn't a lot of correction
to be done
your framing of demographics of identity
be it race or sex or gender whatever the
hell it is as
the thing that needs to be fixed right
now
that's dangerous that is dangerous
because
we were moving in the right direction we
100 were moving in the right direction
people on the left and the right with
the
exception of a few crackpots at the
edges of both extremes
were were becoming more welcoming and
embracing and inclusive
and actually honoring all of the
diversity that humans
are and we need
that in order to actually address the
giant sociopolitical
ai algorithm climate energy
you know all of these other you know and
you know ecosystem destruction
these actual issues that are real
existential threats
and how dare they turn identity into an
existential threat
like this actually really matters how
dare they
yeah it sidelines every other critical
process
and to your point about um
i don't like the term end of empire
because i would like to think that as
much as
we have behaved in an imperial fashion
at times that we aspire to something
better
just better than empire yeah just as
there is obviously a lot of racism
in the history of the country including
its founding um but we aspire to
something better yeah
um but nonetheless the end of whatever
it is the end of republic
right that we may be seeing is i would
argue the result
of this process which
you know at one point one of the uh
people
i've become friends with from my patreon
discussions
posed the question uh is there an
analogy um to senescence that is the
process of growing
feeble and inefficient with age that
happens to bodies is there an analogy
for civilization and what i told him and
i think i did a little video on it
was that it was more than an analogy
that there was in fact the exact
same process and my argument was
for reasons i won't go into here the
reason that we grow feeble and
inefficient with age
is that we are complex creatures with a
relatively small instruction set
that means that instruction set contains
instructions that do many things
one instruction does many things and
when that's true
there will be things that are good for
you early in life
and they're bad for you late in life and
they will get collected by selection
they will be favored
because it's very likely that you will
get the benefit of the early
stuff and you won't live long enough to
suffer from the late stuff and even if
you do most of your reproduction will be
done anyway so it counts less
so selection is constantly accumulating
things that are good for us early and
bad for us late
now here's the problem our political and
economic system does the same goddamn
thing
right if you come up with some new
process right
social media or internal combustion
engines
and it empowers your society process
right hebrew bosch process right
suddenly boom everything's great we can
do stuff we couldn't do before we can
grow crops on
so we couldn't grow them on before we
can go places faster without
breathing hard all this good stuff
emerges from it right
and then the point is okay later on
the costs of these things done at some
scale that the people who invented them
could not have imagined
become evident and you can't do anything
about them why
because once they have become so ungodly
profitable
you can't tell them no you can't turn
them off and at the beginning of
anything
it would be taken as such extraordinary
arrogance to imagine that it would
become a world dominating force
the haber bosch process which allowed
for the fixation of nitrogen
into synthetically produced fertilizers
and thus expanded agriculture
um orders of magnitude more than it had
been possible the intern the
the originator of the internal
combustion engine the originator of
social media and
those last two cases there's more than
two people but you know whatever those
early people were
if they had started thinking about well
what what do we have to put into place
to make sure that this doesn't force the
end of the world
right like what do we have to put in
place to make sure that there will be
controls on it so that the naturally
evolving processes don't actually take
over
most of the people in their startup or
whatever the equivalent of the startup
would have been back at the
you know early 20th century would have
laughed at them you can't spend time
there you can't spend your resources
there we're trying to make a go of it
we're trying to get this amazing new
technology out there into the world
you don't think about putting the brakes
on it before it even has momentum
no in fact this is what the right fears
about the left
is at the point that you make an
internal combustion engine and you've
come up with something i mean
crude oil literally used to sit as a
nuisance on the surface of the earth
right it was a problem sludge you grew
up near one of these problems
in the tar pits in la brea in l.a but it
used to be much more widespread than
that the idea that you could fractionate
that material
and use it to transport goods
arbitrarily
long distances it's unimaginable it's
unimaginably awesome and
the idea of the buzzkill that's wagging
their finger at such a process and
saying don't you realize
you could screw up the atmosphere with
that it's like how much of this would
you have to do before you even affected
the atmosphere and it's like well
ultimately you'll get there right um so
that very thing the fact that you need a
process that allows people to discover
[ __ ] without
people wagging their fingers at them and
saying you never know what the
downstream consequences are going to be
right
that voice has to shut up but there has
to be some process
that recognizes you know what you do
enough of that you will alter something
that matters
and we have to be able to say no to you
at that point even after you've become a
tycoon
right so especially at that point right
we have to be able to say no yeah we
have to be able to say no to you more so
the more power you have and and and yet
it's it's also true that some things
that you set in motion
are incredibly difficult to unset in
motion
right and how you even do it i mean you
know the social media one right
at the point that somebody figures out
how to connect a group of people who are
interested in you know making
models of famous battles right if you're
making miniature models of famous
battles and you're gathering on the
internet to talk to other people who are
hundreds of thousands of miles from you
right and somebody's looking at that
thinking you know this
this process that could get away from us
it could derange us we could
stop being able to think collectively
about how to behave as a society
that sounds nuts right but lo
and behold you start dealing with you
know
machine learning and search and feed
algorithms and
filter bubbles and all of this and next
thing you know there's like an honest
debate about whether two plus two
actually equals
four it's right well
it's a debate but it's not honest let's
put it this way
maybe that's even worse yes whatever
debate it is that can catch
fire that has us debating this that has
us you know uh
looking at the question of whether or
not to you know
eliminate the police because maybe that
would be better all of these things are
nuts so my
point would be the senescence of
civilization would sound exactly like
this basically here's the point
what does senescence sound like in a
person it very often sounds like
dementia that's what happens when a
brain is suffering all the downstream
consequences of whatever made it
vibrant as in youth right
and this is like societal dementia
and it has exactly the nature that
you're pointing to you've got two groups
we agree on what the failure mode is
right it's some kind of authoritarian
evil
that we don't want and both groups think
the other one is going to bring it
except that it's also true that some
members of both groups
only don't like authoritarian regimes
when they're not in power
right and they won't say that out loud
uh
but it's clearly true and this is
something that we've been saying since
um since before evergreen went public
but that the goal is not about
reversing oppression it's about turning
the tables of oppression
and um you know that that is that is
just true
we've seen that over and over and over
again and
um it has it has no place in this moment
in history and yet it is claiming the
throne
at this moment in history well and you
know i keep struggling for a better
analogy
than a ship but it is as if we are on a
ship
on which our very survival depends we're
somehow in the middle of the pacific
if the ship sinks there's no one to come
get us
it's just simply our ship you know two
people
a nazi and a jew on the same ship in the
middle of the pacific ought to agree
that the ship is actually top priority
right yeah
because absent it they're both doomed so
well so at at one level in terms of
individuals making bad decisions right
now
uh a lot of the people who are very very
confused
are millennials uh who were parented
really badly not because their parents
were mean or evil but because they
accepted a stupid
parenting ideology of snowplowing and
parenting and
helicoptering all risk and challenge
away from their children
at the same time that uh
the elites in the west were grabbing
more and more power for themselves so
now we arrive at today
with a group of up-and-coming you know
adults
up and coming adults and adults who have
rarely experienced real risk and
challenge in their lives because just
within their
tiny family structure they were
protected from all of it if they were of
a certain socioeconomic class as
many of the activists were and
simultaneously
there is an abdication of responsibility
for the common good at the higher levels
and so we have these people on the
streets now who
are you know fighting fighting fighting
you know fighting against the man or
whatever
whatever they imagine it is um because
someone has always been there to take
care of their problems for them someone
has always been there with the with the
juice boxes to get back to that
and in fact the real power has walked
away
with their goodies and has left a vacuum
at the top
and the parents who created them in part
helped create the mess of a whole
generation of kids who are now adults
who don't know how to behave like adults
because they never had challenger risk
as children
are breaking things in the streets
because i imagine their senses that
things always get put right
there's no one around to put these
things right they are breaking things
that cannot be put right
especially by their nimrod parents who
protected them from
all risk in the first place right you're
attacking
the ship or whatever analog for it there
is
yeah and the point is look kids
we may not be able to stop you from
doing that but do you know what happens
if you succeed
right in attempting to stop you we're
actually
you know doing you a service because you
if you succeed
you'll you'll doom us all and so i don't
know what i don't know
exactly how that message gets through
yeah we'll say hey zach could you put up
the uh
new york times article
so i just want to stop here briefly and
say
that we saw today this article
emerges uh how a pledge to dismantle the
minneapolis police
collapsed and i i was thinking of
reading a few paragraphs but i i won't i
think the point here
is that many people on the city council
agreed
to abolish the minneapolis police and
they are now discovering
that a nobody wants this or at least
nobody smart does
and b that it's an insane thing to even
consider
and so they're trying to i have not seen
this article is the idea that it
this policy was enacted a few months ago
and it started to
come into play and lo and behold it's
not a good idea it was
three three months ago and the fact is
it's not
popular people you know
black people prominent among them of
course because
they need the police as much as anybody
don't like this and so
what i've come to see is that you know
the people definitely want us to abolish
the police
the public does not right and it's like
well what do you mean well the people is
like this tiny little group of
folks who are either confused
or malevolent or a combination of the
two they're out of control they don't
know how anything works yeah and so
they're you know they're having a
tantrum
and it is um causing
society to bend as if it is the public
demanding these things which the public
is not and so
somehow uh the public needs to reassert
itself because the people are gonna get
us killed
that's good yep um so i would just
not a millennial judith butler who is
the um sort of spokesperson originator
of gender theory she's in her 60s
an academic um just had an interview in
the new states and i'd like to just read
a little bit from
from this interview um she she has given
us a ton
of the nonsense and the crazy that um
that we are living through today and
then i want to provide a couple of
examples of how of how nuts her ideology
is so
really her book um oh
zach just keep it on both of us for the
moment um
yeah actually you can put put my put my
screen up for a moment
um this is the new statesman uh from a
couple days ago
and being interviewed on the culture
wars jk rowling and living in
anti-intellectual times
so she published a book 30 years ago
called gender trouble
in which she introduces the idea of
gender's performance
and asks how we define quote the
category of women
okay so i'm going to read a little bit
from this but um zach give me my screen
back so i can i just
have some quotes she says i find it
worrisome that suddenly the
trans-exclusionary radical feminist
position is understood as commonly
accepted or even mainstream
i think it is actually a fringe movement
that is seeking to speak in the name of
the mainstream and that our
responsibility is to refuse to let that
happen
so the new statesman says one example of
mainstream public discourse on this
issue in the uk
is the argument about allowing people to
self-identify in terms of their gender
in an open letter she published in june
j.k rowling articulated the concern that
this would quote throw open the doors of
bathrooms and changing rooms to any man
who believes or feels he's a woman
potentially putting women at risk of
violence butler responds
if we look closely at the example that
you characterize as mainstream we can
see that a domain of fantasy is at work
one which reflects more about the
feminist who has such a fear than any
actually existing situation in trans
life
the feminist who holds such a view
presumes that the penis does define the
person
and that anyone with a penis would
identify as a woman for the purposes of
entering such changing rooms and posing
a threat to the women inside
it assumes that the penis is the threat
or that any person who has a penis who
identifies as a woman is engaging in a
base deceitful and harmful form of
disguise
this is a rich fantasy and one that
comes from powerful fears but it does
not describe a social reality
trans women are often discriminated
against in men's bathrooms and their
modes of self-identification
are ways of describing a lived reality
one that cannot be captured or regulated
by the fantasies brought to bear upon
them the fact that such fantasies passes
public argument is itself cause for
worry
she uses the word fantasy or a billion
times in this paragraph
and she engages in really crappy logic
in a lot of places uh and the idea that
someone who calls yourself a feminist
and is actually this like
icon in a way that you know ruth bader
ginsburg
actually is and this woman has no
business standing for women
in any way but her work is in women's
studies programs
across the country you know probably
almost every class that calls itself
gender studies or women's studies
the idea that oh my god i just i
i can't i can't even believe that she
would say some of this stuff
um and you know that anyone is arguing
uh that all people who are trans cause
problems now
right no one is saying that and you know
maybe
maybe a handful of extreme extreme
bigots maybe but really no one is saying
that so just
one more little um quote here butler
feminists know that women with ambition
are called monstrous
or that women who are not heterosexual
are pathologized
we do since when yeah since when uh we
fight those misrepresentations because
they are false and because they reflect
more about the misogyny of those who
make demeaning caricatures and they do
about the complex social diversity of
women
i'd say butler's the misogynist here but
okay women should not engage in the
forms of phobic caricature by which
they've been traditionally demeaned
and by women i mean all those who
identify in that way
new statesman says how much is toxicit
how much is toxicity on this issue a
function of culture wars playing out
online
butler i think we are living in
anti-intellectual times
and that this is evident across the
political spectrum to which i say judith
butler you created
you really helped create these
anti-intellectual times like this
this is on you and all of your comrades
and your peers and your colleagues and
you indoctrinated an entire generation
of students who looked around for my
majors and thought oh women's studies
that sounds interesting we know people
who major in women's studies
they're not loons you aren't inherently
alone if you go into that field
but it it lunifies people it has a hard
time not and you know some people have
resisted
but it's hard not to when this is the
kind of garbage rhetoric that you that
you see and so
i just want to point out two just two
tiny downstream effects of this kind of
this kind of garbage um and my link's
not gonna work um
zach if you would show here's just a
tweet
from a couple weeks ago let's stop
angrily denying trans girls experiences
of period symptoms
this person says and it gets almost 4
000 likes
people like to bring up science to
discredit us but studies into our
biology are still grossly underfunded
wait what so
that is a direct intellectual descendant
of judith butler
right there that is incoherent
science denying biology denying
female and male difference denying
nonsense
okay if i can have my screen back sack
please uh
and another one is
comes out of the harvard originated
gender science lab
um so uh this is zach
thank you um this is out of harvard the
gender sci lab is a collaborative
interdisciplinary research lab dedicated
to generating feminist concepts
methods and theories for scientific
research on sex and gender
that might sound to most people like
okay fine
but they they are a tiny step from
saying they're trying to do feminist
science
and um there's no such thing there's no
such thing as feminist economics
it's like it's not a thing you can't do
science
when you already have a lens and
therefore a set of answers
that you're trying to arrive at in
advance that's not science that's the
opposite of science
and so just a i have a particular
example from here but just an anecdote
which
um i was reminded of reading that just
now um
years ago when i was looking for a
publisher for my first book
antipode about my life and research in
madagascar
my agent got a bite from actually a
small press here in portland
when we lived in the midwest we lived in
michigan at the time i had never lived
in the pacific northwest at that point
and this uh little press which i called
itself a feminist press
was really excited about this book of
mine
and in their description to me of what
they were excited about they said this
is going to be feminist science you're
a feminist scientist and i said to them
and i was
i it was probably foolish at one level
to reject an
offer of publication when i never had a
book published and i was just a graduate
student at the time
but but i politely said no and i said i
can be and do like to identify as a
feminist this was back in 2000 2001
uh and i definitely am a scientist but
those are two different things
and science cannot have an adjectival
label attached
attached to it and remain science it
cannot that is not what science is
yep no i and you can you and i
both made this point repeatedly that if
you attach an agenda label
to science you are um invalidating it
you know
right you know if somebody said democrat
science you'd know
there was a problem feminist science
makes exactly as much sense
exactly so one more thing on my screen
zach
the people associated with the gender
sci institute include a lot of people
who you know many of whom i hope
and presume are doing good work here we
have of course the obligate pronouns
she her he him she her
here we have catherine jill's son does
not use pronouns
does not use pronouns not even they them
which itself
wraps us in knots and disables
normal conversation but does not use
pronouns
and so i was reminded zack thank you
of what douglas murray said
in his uh recent excellent joe rogan
appearance
when he was talking about people coming
out as non-binary he said
it's people declaring themselves look at
me it's just
it's just an attention grab it's a
narcissistic little way
to to claim something of meaning in a
universe that seems probably big and
fraught and anonymous
and like it won't pay any attention to
you but for god's sake figure out
something interesting about yourself
something interesting about yourself i'm
sure there's something that doesn't
involve
don't use pronouns with me that's not
who i am
no actually if you're going to speak
english we're going to use pronouns
i must say um i don't need to look at
this person who doesn't use pronouns but
i'd like to talk to them i
cannot overcome my curiosity as to what
that would sound like
no right i so i mean when we were next
level for sure
when we were at evergreen we had to
write these narrative evaluations as you
know
at the end so that didn't have grades
and people will laugh at that but this
was actually a very interesting and
important part of
of the experience for the students um
and so we would write these narrative
evaluations of them
and our prone the pronouns that we used
had to match the pronouns of the gender
that they had on file
and occasionally we had actually
legitimately trans students
yes uh who had not transitioned
officially with the school yet
and so we were in a position of saying
uh
look i i uh
i either have to use the pronouns you
have on file or
every time i want to refer to you i have
to use your name and that's going to be
you know that's going to be very awkward
but i'm
here here are the choices here are the
choices i've been given by the situation
that by the
combination of the college and what you
are declaring yourself as and what you
have done with the college at this point
and um frankly those few cases where
they said okay no pronouns use my name
it it reads it reads super awkward yeah
right um and you know
do it be respectful of course but um
but boy it makes communication difficult
yes
yeah it's almost as if language evolved
for the purpose of communication rather
than
uh this look at me peacocking whatever
it is
um yeah p henning i don't know what it
is but um
yes it's it's awfully awkward i guess it
has to be pee chickening because that's
the only gender-neutral term
whoa i don't even know what that means
i'm going to take some time to parse
that
yeah all right um well where does this
leave us i think
um yeah i think this leaves us
uh just about ready to take a 15-minute
break
uh to but before we go and say a few
things about
um what else we've got going on which is
that our
private uh patreon q a is tomorrow at 11
a.m
pacific for those uh who are uh
patrons of mine at the five dollar and
up level
and um probably before we meet again
next week for our next live stream um if
we don't come back until next saturday
you will have had your first
of the month um long form patreon
conversation
with the patrons at the 100 level yep
next saturday from 10 to 12 pacific and
you can also
get access to the discord server on
either of our patreons
and go to the clips channel for clips
what else i don't know maybe maybe
that's
that's it all right all right so that
means we are facing
this uh intermission and we will see you
in 15 minutes and we'll answer your
super chat questions
then all right be well
[Music]
[Music]
you